Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
for the new marvel wolverine trailer a lot of you
asked me to do a video for this so i'll explain
what's going on there's a couple really big easter
eggs but it looks like we have another shut up and
take my money situation if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're going to start seeing more mutants and x-men
characters showing up in marvel phase 4 movies
and disney plus series they're sort of creating
the circumstances that are necessary to introduce
mutants into the mcu right now in fact billy and
tommy from one division are technically the first
brand new mutants inside the mcu since the start
of marvel phase four even though scarlet witch
and quicksilver were kind of mutants in the mcu
before this but there are a couple big easter eggs
in this that you probably spotted some of them are
a little bit more obvious than others so obviously
there's the quebec license plate that reads
hlk 181 which is uh easter egg for incredible
hulk number 181 the first major fight between
wolverine and hulk it wasn't his first appearance
it was just the first time they actually fought
each other in the first time wolverine was on the
cover of a comic book there's also the princess
bar on the chalkboard which is a bar and mad
report that was part of a big wolverine story
and a tourist poster also from madrapur to the
right of this meaning that this scene is taking
place in madrapur a large part of the game will
either be in mad report or the entire game will
take place there in madrid obviously big mcu
connection we just saw it during the falcon
and winter soldier series so the actual princess
bar was first featured in marvel comics presents
number one back in september 1988 mad reporter
itself obviously which we just got done watching
on falcon winter soldier sharon carter the power
broker obviously a big base of operations there
during the wolverine story there was mostly a
bunch of x-men characters that wolverine was
fighting like you have patch tiger the marauders
morlocks reavers so a lot of the stickers and
things that you see plastered all over the bar
are easter eggs and references to that the song
that was playing during the trailer i had to take
it out just for copyright reasons because music
is heavily copyrighted on youtube but the trailer
song was james cars the dark end of the street and
even though the actual song was just meant to be a
straightforward country cheating ballad the lyrics
read at the dark end of the street that's where we
always meet hiding in the shadows where we don't
belong living in darkness to hide our wrong in the
context of this wolverine story that takes place
during this is a reference to wolverine doing
really really awful things to even worse people
under cover of darkness in this really dark place
of mad rapport mad report initially showed up
during the x-men comics like i said it's mostly
been a port of call for villains like if you're
familiar with corto maltese in the dc universe
and the batman comics they've used it in a bunch
of dc movies as well too they just used it in the
james gunn suicide squad movie recently it's the
same idea it's just a safe haven for all kinds of
shady stuff so in the mcu obviously sharon carter
became the power broker during that five year time
jump after the snap after avengers infinity war
she built up this criminal empire she wound
up funding the new version of the weapons plus
program to create a new version of a super soldier
serum to create a bunch of super soldiers to sell
out to the highest bidders around the world
even though they didn't end falcon and winter
soldier on mad rapport she is still the power
broker she still has her criminal empire that
centered on madrapore she's just been pardoned and
welcomed back into the us government so at the end
of the series she gets on that phone call with her
people that are back on madrapore her power broker
people and says that they're basically open for
business like she has access to all this weapons
and technology through the us government now and
they're just going to be stealing it and selling
it off to the highest bidder most of that i think
they'll cover during captain america 4 when we
get to that movie because they just announced a
new captain america movie with falcon's version
of captain america winter soldier will come back
for that and they'll probably also pay off the big
thunderbolts julie louis dreyfus val stuff during
that as well also by that time we'll probably have
seen a couple other mutants pop up in the mcu
other x-men characters and also early theory
on the new version of wolverine inside the mcu
james hallett would have existed for a long time
but because we have the sharon carter power broker
stuff with her now pilfering the us government
selling off their technology to the highest bidder
around the world it would be a really cool setup
for wolverine if they had her steal weapons plus
tech from thunderbolt ross and sell it on the dl
to the weapon x branch of the canadian government
and then they wind up using that technology
to mint the brand new mcu wolverine meaning
we would see the new version of wolverine
after captain america 4. that would be a really
badass post-credits scene for that movie the whole
thing with the incredible hulk 181 easter egg
so the comic book obviously is famous because
it's the first full appearance of wolverine on the
cover of a comic book but like i said technically
his actual first full appearance was at the very
end of the previous issue incredible hulk 180
and even though later comics would explain his
backstory as james hallett and how he was born a
mutant in the 1800s and they just lived through
many many wars eventually becoming part of the
weapon x program getting the adamantium bonded
to his skeleton during this very first storyline
with the hook when he debuted he just debuted as
the wolverine so the short backstory on this very
first storyline is that he'd been dispatched by
department h the part of the canadian government
that controlled all superhuman activity in
canada like alpha flight for example so they're
also loosely connected to the weapon x program
too they dispatch him to stop the hulk after
he rampages across the canadian border and gets
into this huge battle with the villain wendigo
originally wolverine had no connection to
thunderbolt ross or the weapons plus program they
kind of retconned that weapon's plus backstory in
later but the hulk vs wolverine storyline turned
into one of those situations where the enemy of
my enemy is my friend so the hulk surmised that
if wolverine was also trying to fight wendigo
and wendigo was his enemy then wolverine must
be a friend but of course they spend a bunch
of the issue fighting each other in the next
issue as well but what happens is the beginning
of the next issue 182 department h shows up and
basically stops their fight ordering wolverine
to come back like you failed stop fighting him
so the very first hulk vs wolverine fight kind of
ended in a draw that many many rematches over the
years probably one of the most famous being
the old man logan's storyline but a really
cool connection to what if because we're in the
middle of marvel's what-if episodes there's a
really cool twist on that first hulk vs wolverine
fight in the what if comics so what if issue 31
was what if wolverine had killed the hulk and it's
a re-telling of their very first fight during the
events of incredible hulk number 181 during that
fight wolverine goes rogue and decides to kill
the hulk using his adamantium claws to just rip
out hulk's throat and even though technically
his gamma power should heal him instantly during
this what if story they just say that the damage
killed the hulk talking about connections to loki
the multiverse nexus points that sort of serves
as a nexus point for this version of wolverine he
becomes an alternate universe version goes super
dark and winds up joining magneto's brotherhood of
mutants instead of joining the x-men most what-if
stories have pretty downer endings then he winds
up killing magneto after he tried to kill jean
grey and as magneto lay dying bleeding out he
uses his powers of magnetism to force wolverine
to kill himself manipulating his adamantium claws
into his own throat so it was meant to be a darkly
poetic ending for this alternate universe version
of wolverine he was dying in the same way that he
had initially killed the hulk creating the nexus
event that caused him to go down this darker path
oh the irony it's kind of like what if episode
four is ending with dark doctor strange
completely foo barring his version of the
universe links for all my what if episode
videos down in the description i know you're all
asking what's going on with wolverine in the mcu
now that marvel has the characters back i've
already talked about how the eternals movies
some of the other upcoming movies are slowly
setting up the concept of mutants inside the
mcu but there was also a recent report that kevin
feige had tried to get hugh jackman to guest star
in doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness as
part of the scarlet witch villains subplot
wherein at least according to rumors scarlet witch
will be one of the main antagonists not the true
main villain but during the movie doctor
strange will have to try and stop her from
completely destroying all of reality while she's
trying to find her children in the multiverse
and while she's tearing through everyone in
alternate dimensions with her chaos magic powers
apparently she is supposed to fight a major fox
x-men character because it's a big multiverse
story so you expect some other characters
from other franchises like they're doing in
spiderman no way home with the tobey maguire
characters and the andrew garfield characters
like doctor strange is doing the same thing only
now they're doing it with fox x-men characters and
originally the report was that marvel wanted to
get hugh jackman's wolverine to come back for this
big scarlet witch fight but according to reports
it just didn't work out either he turned them down
or there were scheduling issues or whatever so
wolverine is not going to be in doctor strange 2
but everyone now thinks that the replacement
fox x-men character the scarlet witch will fight
is going to be james mcavoy's professor x because
it had to be a really powerful x-men character
kevin feige said in general talking about the new
version of the x-men movie that they're working
on they haven't had any formal conversations
about recasting a new version of wolverine yet
but that is the idea that they'll introduce a
new version of mcu wolverine and if we see hugh
jackman ever come back it would just be in a cameo
scene in a big multiverse type of avengers movie
like a secret wars movie we do have the kang
multiverse ward that they just started on loki
thank you very much sylvie so it sounds like
marvel is slowly setting up a secret war story
line but we probably won't see them pay that off
till way down the road after they've rebooted a
new version of the solo x-men movie in the mcu
but it does sound like they have plans to mix
in some legacy fox x-men characters coming back
like some of the big ones with brand new recast
versions of some of the characters any tips on uh
getting into the mcu there cork but if you spotted
any of the big easter eggs in this wolverine
trailer just write them below in the comments
and what i'll do is when the game does come out in
a couple years it'll be like 2024 2025 i will give
away copies i've got a couple big videos that
i'm working on my full marvel what if episode 6
video will also post wednesday just like normal
so make sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss any of those everyone click here
for my full shang chi post credit scene video
and click here for that really cool wolverine
deleted scene where he gets the yellow costume
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!